what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper Suite a tiff 2022 I've got the
team behind Muro here huge
congratulations I don't know I I just
started the movie I didn't I didn't
realize how ambitious you were gonna get
as things progressed it is like I mean a
like a Hollywood level action film with
obviously a lot more to the story than
just that but I was very very impressed
by the production value of this movie
thank you right on yeah I'll take that
um I will start with you and I will ask
you to do something that I have a
feeling a million people are going to
ask you to do today can you give us a
brief description of what muru is about
for anybody out there who has not heard
of this film yet well muru is a story
that encapsulates a hundred years of
history in terms of the government's
relationship with the special tribe
called tuhoy Beck in New Zealand and the
film is about a day emblematic of this
relationship where the government
decided to push a red button on this
community saying there were terrorists
here so to my left I have Cliff Curtis
who plays the the local police Sergeant
who's sort of torn between loyalties of
do I see of the badge or do I protect my
community and right here Mr J Ryan he
plays Captain Gallagher and he is a man
with a scene of Doubt given this order
from the chain of command above him and
here's the seed of doubt and by the end
of the film
he's basically a new man with a new
realization all right to follow up on
that and add a little more to it can you
tell us a little bit about some of the
truth that inspired what we see in the
film but then also what inspired this
the decision to make this a reaction
rather than a recreation of those past
events because I feel like you know a
lot of more traditional films out there
would have gone that route
we did a lot of research we've done
we've we've got a lot of relationships
here just sitting on this one chair on
this one so far and this research it's
it led us to this pathway
the government enacted a raid against
this community and by raid we say they
brought in the sdg they treated like a
Black Ops operation in terms of domestic
terrorists live here
and that wasn't the case so the
inspiration behind creating the film and
creating a response to this film and to
the raid is actually about lifting the
truth the masking power seeing who these
people truly were seeing who this
community and iwi and tribe truly are
beyond the headlines that seem to
snapshot us and encapsulate what
happened on this one day
it's incredibly powerful the first thing
I did after I finished the movie was
obviously go down the rabbit hole of
Googling everything I I mean that should
be like the intended effect of this
movie and I think it's going to have
that impact on a lot of people it's a
big rabbit hole it's a deep rabbit hole
and this this why we chose to respond is
to get beyond that to get Beyond uh the
simple headline and and into the lives
and relationships that really Define
these people not the government's action
against them I feel like this there's a
lot there's a lot to discover I feel
like this is just me blabbing about how
much I love your movie but the other
quality I love about it is how many how
many different characters were allowed
access to where whether you could
classify someone as good bad or
something in between I understand what's
motivating every single person and it
draws a newcomer to this situation
deeper into the material with a better
understanding of it I'm very impressed
thank you I just like reviewed your
movie right to your face I mean it
though for the two of you I know you've
been working on the idea for this movie
for a little while now what would you
say is the biggest difference for the
first way you envision this movie
playing out compared to what we wind up
seeing in the final film
all your questions are great and in
terms of you know defining enjoying
these characters and the acts that
they'll travel it's it's it was
important for us to get Way Beyond the
black and white headline into this gray
area into this human area into this this
place of Discovery for each of our
characters who are on this chessboard
and it's a big chessboard because this
is a deep rich Valley and community
in terms of the original draft well it
was very faithful uh faithful to a small
snapshot and what we were able to do was
a lot of direction from tuhoi themselves
and each other was was create more
context give deeper understanding and um
and really color and shade
the full relationship now whether we
achieved that in 100 minutes I'd like to
think we got very very close we
certainly aim to I'm very impressed by
how much you achieve in 100 minutes uh
Cliff for you specifically with taffy
even having been involved in the
development of the project for so long
is there anything you discovered about
the character that you weren't able to
tap into until you hit set working with
your scene partners and in that
environment
another great question another great
question
um
I'm still
affected by the your opening questions
in terms of
trying to wrap it up into a single
answer I think like
we're indigenous storytellers so in
terms of indigenous being the native
people of aotearoa New Zealand and this
is a this is a story on the impact of
being indigenous in our own country and
then wrapping it up in a cinematic kind
of gift to our audience trying to get it
into that 100 minutes in a way that's
like worthy of cinema right
um which means that we got into the into
the area of Storytelling which we call
allegory where we look at society and we
look at the patterns of society and we
look at say where is there a lesson here
is this something that we can that we
can learn about who we are as human
beings and I think in terms of
indigenous storytelling what's
interesting to me is what you touched on
with that very lovely com uh compliment
really is that uh the traditional
storytelling style is
um protagonist antagonist good bad right
wrong good evil right
indigenous storytelling is is somewhat
more complex it's about families and
communities it's not about the
individual and I think structurally what
charipa really offers as an indigenous
Storyteller is is getting into with my
character
I got my class 2 license so I could
drive a bus my first two days on set is
I had to drive a bus with children real
children from that community and his own
children in the bus
my first day on set on a live Road
in a remote location with real cars and
then my next scene I had to have the
Elders of that community in the bus
you know
and then it was bringing the helicopter
and then bringing a helicopter and
coordinate all of that so what I
discovered is simultaneously is
um the exhilaration of making a movie
that's gonna have a sense of action and
be in the community in the valley on
location very remote during covert
but uh being responsible to this
community
actually metaphorically as a Storyteller
driving the bus with that community
while acting on screen and handling the
wheel driving
the story so I don't think I could think
of a more visceral way to experience the
movie than that yeah it's pretty great
you're gonna drive a bus bro you're
going to be a cop but a cop that the
world has never seen you're going to be
driving a live bus with Elders Community
Elders tribal Elders all our children
and the elders in that bus were there
during the real raids right so we're
reenacting parts of their lives for them
you know we were recreating parts of
their lives for them in a fictional sort
of like allegorical tale wrapped up in
cinema so I've been it's been a great
great journey it's so exciting to be
here
you know to present this at Toronto and
and to a world and and to sort of bring
our indigenous storytelling
uh flows and styles uh to to cinema yeah
you're doing it in a big way right now
it was well worth getting that bus
license yeah yeah he's got it in his
pockets
but if you ain't getting this role
unless you get this driver's license do
it any other way that's so funny
I love that you have it on you there's
my license
proof proof there on the back that big
picture that's a bus oh yeah okay he
could do bus tours around Toronto right
now and we'd all jump on and we'd all
have a good job if you ever do that I
will be your first customer sign me up
for that okay
um Jay a question for you I'm actually
gonna borrow uh tiarapa's words from a
different interview I don't know if this
was the case for you but he said that
after you all did a table read of the
script that the reaction from the cast
was great trepidation did you feel that
yourself and if so why was that the case
yeah no actually there was a great
Silence of what we just read and
experienced and heard amongst each other
for the first time hearing it out loud
come off the page I remember when I read
the script for the first time I think
two pages in I was in awe I hadn't even
read any dialogue or scene work yet it
was just sort of the statements up the
front and the statement was that you
know this uh event happened in 2007 but
it also happened a hundred years before
this and another 100 years before that
so this is an ongoing history between
these people of tuhoi and the crown
um so for me to learn that history
within a couple of pages was was quite
shocking and I felt the weight of what
we're about to to go on and do also for
a New Zealand film to have all of these
aspects like you say it has the scope of
a Hollywood
um Blockbuster but with a real depth
um so to be able to do that Justice I
mean I didn't really know tea or Cliff
at the time before before we went in so
um yeah we we all put our armor on and
went to work brought up to Hawaii a
couple times now would you mind just so
our audience knows who they are but also
again you accomplish a whole lot in a
hundred minutes of a running time but
are there any small details about the
history and lifestyle there that you
would just want people to be aware of
even if it's something that isn't like
focused or flat out discussed in the
film
it's a very remote community
and and what we call the farua this
Valley this deep valley where a river
runs down through the valley and out to
the ocean
and in terms of an indigenous Community
it's uh it's sort of shrouded in a way
almost mythological and and how uh
untouched it is uh in some in some ways
it's a remote community and not many
people go up the valley or too deeply
into the valley you know these people
are resilient this community has uh you
know maintained their language and their
way of being
um through all of this conflict and it's
a it's a very it's a great honor for us
as storytellers and filmmakers uh to go
in there into that Community to be
welcomed in and to share that with the
world this is a this is a rare rare uh
honor for us to to be a part of that
community in that way yeah and tuho is
situated basically in the middle of of
New Zealand of the north island and uh
we me and Manu Bennett who plays the
other uh STG cop we were up in the
chopper basically all day long so we
were hovering over the forests and
they're so vast and ancient and they
crawl and they go so high I mean it was
hard for us to get above the tree line
um so it is a very special place it does
have a bit of a unique and mysterious
Vibe going on to most kiwis who are
outside of it
um so to be welcomed in into the village
and um the valley was uh an experience I
won't forget I already got a white noise
is that it is the home of tomahiti
that's where I wanted to go next Segway
and it's the home of tamiiti we were all
so honored and privileged to be welcomed
into his backyard and we all as as Maori
owe so much to tuhoi because of the
conflict and the breakdown in
relationships their autonomy their
self-independence their their language
preservation their tikanga traditional
preservation
every other alien New Zealand hotel or
aspires to be honorary tuhoi okay two
follow-ups I'm determined to squeeze in
before they make me let you go make me
let you guys go first uh tamaiti I was
reading the production notes and it
seems like almost everyone involved has
a really personal connection to him and
what he stands for in his work so can
each of you uh tell us a little bit
about that but also I'm very curious
what was it like approaching him to play
himself in the movie was he totally game
to do it or was there any apprehension
uh I'm no you stop bro I mean yeah
listen he's directed you oh okay okay
I'll prepare something earlier
um I know for me Tommy is Iconic in New
Zealand
um but many people have different
opinions of why he's iconic and you know
the 2007 rage the media really painted
uh a dirty picture of the man and and
the people surrounding him
um to fit their rhetoric you know so for
me it was to be a part of this was to
change that narrative
um I was saying to T the other day my uh
my own father you know when I told him I
was going to do a movie with tomahiti he
was like like isn't that follow like you
know isn't he guilty and I was like no
dad he's not and that's why I'm doing
the movie
um and so when he saw the film recently
he was like oh I get it you know I get
it so that was that's all I needed that
was um that was my goal uh in this piece
yeah I'll jump in so you can wrap it up
but um yeah tell me I've known him for
decades I met him as an artist as a as a
sort of like a uh yeah as an artist you
know he was he was he had a restaurant
uh you know
um he he was he was a DJ and on a local
radio show
um he he was a painter uh you know he
does dance shows so the notion of you
know and he puts on you know politically
driven arch for sure definitely a
political activist absolutely but an
artist first and foremost so the notion
that that when they created this
narrative about him this alternate
universe where he was not these things
uh I knew that I I was all in for
telling the story and sort of saying
okay we you know this is a story that
needs to be told and it needs to be
corrected and in the movie you'll see
him he also collects honey from bees
and I love that I did he's wearing in
the movie that's his honey bee
collecting suit we'll see it on the
runway next season okay I'll leave that
to wrap up for you bro
tomati and my father friends tamiti and
my father-in-law are friends we're
family friends
um but it was still a task to give him
the confidence to know that he could
stand alongside Cliff Curtis J Ryan
Simon Kissel Manu Bennett in this big
this big Community you know in this into
the telling of this big story but all
the words were his words all the
dialogue came from him all the thought
track came from him so we had a read he
rung me up and he said arepa I can do
this
all right someone's about to glare at me
but I'm asking one more question because
you brought up takana you saw it it
happened
um the last person I spoke to about that
was Rachel house and I I hear about it
and it's it just seems like something
that is very specific to that region but
it's something that literally every set
on this planet could benefit from
embracing so can you tell us a little
bit about something that that adds to
the onset environment that you wish you
saw in more Productions out there
uh chica I mean it really comes down to
respectfulness and if you walk into
someone's house
if you walked in someone's like front
yard or backyard into the into their
world whatever it is
it's about being respectful of who you
are and whose environment you're walking
into if you walk in someone else's
environment
um
and bring all of yourself into that
without respecting where you are that's
really the most General broad term of
what I could determine tikanga is
because we all have our own homes we all
have our own ways of being and it's
really about being respectful and about
respecting that what happens in your
house when I'm in your house respecting
what happens in your house
um and what happens in your front or
backyard and respecting you as a human
being
really knowing your family or your
community to like go in with a
predetermined predisposed idea about who
you are what you are
disrespectfully that's not tikonga
that's the opposite of
to add to that
we shot this film in 29 days
and we did not shoot this film on a film
set we shot this in their footer in
their house in their father in their
Valley and the only way that we could
accomplish that ridiculous unattainable
schedule is because of the support and
respect that we had tikanga is about
empowering the person empowering the
community empowering the storytellers
empowering the participants it's the
it's it says that we're going to choose
a way to do it and this is the right way
so tikanga is also about bringing tuhoi
to Toronto
and we've bought aroha Tampa with us who
was a kuya who was there she's one of
our tribal Elders she is a two hoi
rangatira and she has come to Toronto
with us because that is also tikanga
oh so beautiful
I have to let you all go I could talk
about your like 29 days 29 days that's
true huge huge huge congratulations on
what you accomplished I hope you have a
wonderful time celebrating it at the
festival to everybody out there thank
you so much for watching this interview
about muru check it out do not miss it
we will be back soon at the supper Suite
with more Tiff 2022 interviews